in this lesson I'm going to discuss some
trends in acidity and basicity and we'll
work an equilibrium problem or two this
is not meant to be an introductory video
on acidity and basicity you might want
to look for something else if you're
looking for how to derive PKA for this
video you need to have a working
definition of what PKA means and we're
gonna go over some general trends in
organic compounds let's go ahead and get
started the first trend I want to
explore is the acidity of this alcohol
versus the acidity of this thye all
let's look at the pKa values of these
two compounds so acidity is the tendency
to lose a proton so we're talking about
losing these protons here notice the
Thyle is at least five PKA units below
this alcohol this is a more acidic
compound so we need to figure out why
that is sulfur is just below oxygen on
the periodic table so these compounds
are in the same group but we're seeing a
dramatic increase in acidity as we move
down the periodic table this has to mean
that the conjugate base of this acid is
more stabilized than the conjugate base
of this one that's why the compounds
more likely to lose its proton the trend
that we're observing here is due to size
sulfur is much larger than oxygen so we
have this negative charge smeared all
over the surface of this large atom and
that's very stabilizing whereas with the
alkoxide the o- the negative charge is
very concentrated close to the oxygen
atom so since we can't spread out the
negative charge it is less stable
therefore this compound is less likely
to lose its proton this trend is general
and we can look at this again by
comparing the acidity of acids derived
from the halogens
now even though fluorine is the most
electronegative element and you think
that'd be great for housing a negative
charge and it's
not bad it's PKA is quite low however as
we increase the atomic size we can see a
dramatic increase in acidity here as
well with H I being the strongest acid
derived from the halogens iodine is huge
and that negative charge can be spread
out over a very large surface now let's
compare the acidity of ethanol and
acetic acid both of these contain two
carbons in a hydroxyl group but acetic
acid has this other carbonyl here the
pKa of acetic acid in water is
dramatically lower than the pKa of this
alcohol this difference is also
associated with stabilization of the
conjugate base but this time the
stabilization is due to resonance when
we draw the conjugate base of acetic
acid we can a push electrons to spread
the negative charge out over the two
oxygen atoms that arrow pushing looks
like this and the resulting resonance
form has the negative charge on the
other oxygen resonance stabilization of
the conjugate base is a very powerful
effect we can see this dramatic increase
in acidity for this carboxylic acid here
versus this alcohol and we see a PKA
decrease of more than 10 here remember
the scale is logarithmic so that is huge
now let's compare the pKa values of a
couple of carboxylic acids to examine
another trend here we're comparing
acetic acid and trifluoroacetic acid the
pKa of trifluoroacetic acid is negative
compared to this PKA value of around 5
so what's going on here well in both of
these compounds we have the same
resonance effect where we can draw
resonance that looks like this for both
of the conjugate bases of these
compounds however trifluoroacetic acid
has this extra effect where electrons
are pulled through bonds not through
resonance but this CF 3 group is very
strongly electron attracting owing to
the electron
Nativity of the three fluorine atoms
they attract electrons toward themselves
through the bonds and this is called an
inductive effect now notice here that
our pKa difference was more than ten and
here the addition of the tri fluoro
methyl group decreases the pKa by about
five this is a general trend typically
resonance will be a more powerful
stabilizing effect than an inductive
effect and we can see that by comparing
these two trends now let's look at how
charge can influence PKA here we have
the hydronium ion made by the
protonation of water in acid this PKA
value is negative one point seven let's
compare this to the pKa of water recall
that water can act as either an acid or
a base
and when it acts as a base we form the
hydronium ion water itself can act as an
acid and form hydroxide losing this
proton and the pKa value for that
deprotonation is fifteen point seven so
loss of this proton off this charge
species giving oxygen back its lone pair
is very low then we're taking off just
the hydrogen of an O H group similar to
here and we see a similar PKA and let's
just look at the species that results
from the deprotonation of water this is
the hydroxide ion and this really
doesn't have a PKA if you imagine
ripping off this proton we'd end up with
just oxygen with a negative two charge
on it that is super high in energy and
so deprotonation of this is not going to
happen in any practical organic reaction
that we're running but this is a strong
base and we need a way to evaluate
basicity of compounds too so we
mentioned hydroxide is a strong base
water can act as a base and when it does
it forms the hydronium ion now the
hydronium ion does have one lone pair on
oxygen but this is not a basic species
in order to accept another proton and we
have to gain a +2 charge on this very
small molecule and that's really not
going to happen now say we want to
compare the basicity of ammonia versus
this anion formed by the deprotonation
of ammonia often this has a counter ion
maybe a sodium so this might be the
compound sodium amid and this is just
the negative part of that what we can
actually do is look at the conjugate
acids of both of these compounds and
compare their pk's to glean information
about the basicity this compound is the
corresponding conjugate acid of ammonia
and this is the conjugate acid of this
deprotonated species now we can see that
this PKA here is much lower that means
this is a more acidic compound than this
is so this is much more likely to lose
its proton and form this however this
compound isn't very likely to lose a
proton at all it has a really high PKA
so this proton is not very acidic so
once we make this compound its really
unstable it didn't want to lose that
proton so if we have a very high PKA we
know that compound the compound
resulting from its deprotonation will be
the much stronger base therefore this
compound is much more basic than ammonia
so we can generalize a bit and say that
positively charged compounds will make
better acids and negatively charged
compounds analogous compounds will make
better bases pyridine is another base
commonly used in organic reactions it
uses a lone pair on this nitrogen to
accept a proton forming this conjugate
acid the conjugate acid pyridinium has a
pKa of 3.4 so we can see that pyridine
is less basic than ammonia or sodium
Amman now let's look at what happened
when we substitute pyridine with a
couple of different groups at the four
position right here now remember these
compounds won't really have a PKA
relating to protonation of this nitrogen
we need to look at the conjugate acids
so the pKa of this conjugate acid is one
point six much much lower than this
conjugate acid here and the pKa of the
conjugate acid the protonated version of
this is six point zero what that's
telling us is this compound is not as
good of a base the conjugate acid has a
low PKA so it's much more likely to
exist in this form with the proton gone
this compound is a much better base
we've got this higher PKA meaning that
it's much more likely to accept a proton
it doesn't want to lose the proton on
the pyridinium as much as this nitro
compound to examine this trend I find it
useful to look at the conjugate acid and
see if there's any stabilization so now
that I've shown this conjugate acid I
want to know how the sulfur is
influencing this wanting to be
protonated so much more than the Nitro
compound here so I look to this and see
if I see any of these effects and
there's actually a resonance effect here
we can take a lone pair on sulfur and
push through this ring until we are able
to neutralize the positive charge on
nitrogen by giving it electrons back
let's look at what the resonance form
looks like
so this sulfur group is electron
donating we see that we can push
electrons through the system and
neutralize the charge on this conjugate
acid here that means that the charge is
more stabilized once this becomes
protonated and that makes it a better
base so why can't the Nitro stabilize in
the same way
well the Nitro has a formal positive
charge on this nitrogen there are no
electron
that it can use to stabilize a positive
charge forming over here in fact this is
a powerful electron withdrawing group so
this wants to pull electron density away
from the ring away from this nitrogen
making its lone pairs less available to
act as a base and so that's the
contrasting effect that we're seeing
here I just want to point out that
there's two ways to look at this I
always like to draw the conjugate acid
and then see if I can draw resonance
stabilization however you could actually
draw resonance using this molecule here
and both of these ways are equal you
could do it your way if you if you find
this is better but if we draw resonance
with the sulfur we can draw a resonance
form of this with a negative charge on
nitrogen if we can put a negative charge
on nitrogen well it's way more likely to
act as a base so you can draw the
conjugate acid and look for resonance or
you can look for resonance in your
original compound if that makes more
sense to you okay now that we know a
little bit about acids and bases we need
to know if we're choosing a good acid or
base to actually do a reaction and to
figure this out we'll need to look at
equilibrium we know from our discussion
that pyridine is a base and that ethanol
is an acid so if we go into the lab and
we treat ethanol with pyridine will that
be strong enough to deprotonate it we
need a way to figure this out and
fortunately we can use PKA values to
figure out the direction of the
equilibrium and estimate how far the
equilibrium lies in that direction what
we first need to do is draw the
conjugates of these
so imagine ethanol is deprotonated by
pyridine we'll draw the conjugate acid
of this and the conjugate base of this
compound now remember we don't have a
pKa for this and this has a negative
charge so we didn't really don't have a
pKa for this but we can compare the
pka's of these acids so this conjugate
acid has a pKa of 3.4 and this conjugate
acid has a pKa of v
eighteen point nine this species is more
acidic so it is much more likely to give
up a proton by quite a lot remember this
is logarithmic so we're looking at a
difference of 12 ish so that's powers of
10 we're talking here so the equilibrium
really lies very far in this direction
this compound is much more likely to
give up a proton to ethanol and so these
are the species that predominate in
solution by quite a lot so here our
equilibrium lies very far toward our
reactants let's look at one more example
so here we're asking the question is
NaOH a good base to deprotonate my Thyle
let's draw a conjugate acid of NaOH and
the conjugate base of our Thyle so
here's one acid and here's the other
let's add in our pKa values this PKA is
about 10 and water and this is fifteen
point seven so we can see our Thyle is
much more likely to give up a proton
being the stronger acid in our
equilibrium we have a pKa difference of
about six so that translates to the
equilibrium line quite far in this
direction so NaOH is a great base to
deprotonate our Thyle and we might want
to use that deprotonated Thyle in an sn2
reaction or something like that
KP here if you learn something give me a
thumbs up on the way out and for more
chemistry subscribe to my channel